Rich simp men changed the game when men
decided that they've got a load of money
in their pocket and they decided to
start flying women out and they decided
to start paying for everything for women
because they had it what did what did
Lil Wayne said it ain't tricking if you
got it yeah it is that's what he said
right he said it's not tricking if you
got it so these rich rappers who were
still Sims but they had a lot of money
started to change the game because a lot
of women started to go to these concerts
go to these rappers and these rappers
would pay for everything they' fly them
out they' do all of this kind of stuff
and then those women started to think oh
yeah okay well so and so flew me out so
and so gave me money so and so done that
for me and so rich simp men also had a
hand